Sometimes the most unlikely data can be the most useful and
lead to savings, due to better planning. For example, a conventional system
for coordinating logistics might send the closest truck to a factory to
pick up a package. However, it might be that the closest truck
is not the best solution. Perhaps there's a traffic jam, or
the closest route is actually on small roads that take a long
time. Maybe the truck doesn't have enough free space for the new
load. So what kind of data would be helpful making a better
plan that could save money and time for
the company. Would current GPS data for all trucks
be useful? Or how about the current plan for each truck for the day? Would it be
helpful if we had real time information about
the traffic in the area? How about the current
load in each truck and its volume and weight.
May be the fuel efficiency of our different vehicles.